embarking on the journey to master
artificial intelligence is a to setting
sail in a vast sea of knowledge where
the Winds of programming languages the
currents of mathematical foundations and
the unchartered territories of
specialized AI tools converge python
often hailed as the ai's best friend
takes the lead in this Maritime
Expedition its adaptability and a rich
ecosystem of libraries such as tensor
flow and Pyon transform it into a
trustworthy guide for those venturing
into the unexplored Realms of AI as you
navigate through the pythonic waters you
encounter another linguistic companion R
the artistic sibling to python often
employed in research and statistical
domains R adds a unique brush stroke to
the canvas of AI exploration its
statistical provis and expressive syntax
makes it an invaluable companion when
you seek a deeper understanding of the
data Landscapes you
Traverse next up is the mathematical
Foundation linear algebra emerges as the
superhero capes of the mathematical
Ensemble guiding you through vectors
metrices igon values and igon vectors
these elements seemingly Arcane form the
Bedrock of many AI algorithms ensuring
the seamless operation of your digital
vessel picture linear algebra as the
compass steering your AI through the
complexities of data Landscapes
providing Direction when faced with the
uncertainities of the journey in the
vast sea of mathematical knowledge the
AI Navigator encounters another
essential tool calculus in this context
calculus becomes the trusty GPS guiding
you through the twists and turns of
optimization algorithms derivatives and
integrals once considered mathematical
intricacies transform into indispensable
tools helping you navigate the
undulating terrain of AI
development statistics emerges as the
Storyteller in this Maritime Adventure
revealing insights and narratives from
the data ladden Landscapes you explore
probability distributions hypothesis
testing and regression analysis become
the literary elements of your AI
narrative statistics guides your AI in
crafting a compelling story ensuring
that the insights drawn from data are
not merely numbers but meaningful tales
that inform decision making and
algorithmic Behavior now with linguistic
and mathematical foundations firmly in
place the AI Odyssey charts a course
Into the Heart of artificial
intelligence machine learning in this
realm you the Navigator transition from
a linguistic and mathematical guide to a
mentor teaching algorithms to recognize
patterns and make predictions supervised
learning becomes your teaching ground a
realm where your AI learns by example
unsupervised learning emerges as the
Uncharted Territory where your AI
explodes independently uncovering hidden
patterns without explicit guidance
clustering algorithms akin to Invisible
guid
help your AI organize the chaos within
data Landscapes revealing structures
that may not be apparent at first glance
the AI Odyssey reaches its cresendo with
the entrance of deep learning the
Rockstar of artificial intelligence
neural networks both convolutional and
recurrent become the instruments in your
digital band deep learning showcases
mindblowing performances in image
recognition
language processing and Beyond picture
neural networks as the maos conducting
Symphonies of data unraveling intricate
Melodies hidden within the vast Seas of
information data handling emerges as the
backstage crew ensuring that everything
is in order for the grand performance
libraries like pandas and numai in
Python take Center Stage preparing your
data for Limelight pandas the conductor
orchestrates the data Ensemble ensuring
each element plays its part harmoniously
numai the instrumentalist performs the
numerical acrobatics necessary to
transform raw data into the coherent
Melody that AI can comprehend SQL the
language of databases becomes your means
of communication with the data
reservoirs just as a sailor needs a
reliable method to communicate with the
depths of the ocean SQL enables you to
manage and retrieve data effectively SQL
acts as the linguistic bridge between
your AI and the vast databases ensuring
a smooth and efficient exchange of
information as the journey unfolds the
AI Navigator delves into the Realms of
natural language processing NLP and text
processing NLP becomes the translator
enabling your AI to understand and
interact with human language picture NLP
as the Rosetta Stone of artificial
intelligence breaking down the barriers
between human expression and algorithmic
comprehension text processing libraries
such as nltk and Spacey becomes the
linguistic AIDS aiding your AI in
parsing understanding and responding to
textual information the maritime
Adventure extends further F into the
domain of computer vision where image
processing becomes the guide to teaching
your AI to see open CV the artist's
pallet enables you to work with images
enhancing and transforming them for the
ai's Discerning eyes object detection
and recognition facilitated by tools
like YOLO or SSD add a layer of
sophistication to ai's visual
understanding reinforcement learning
emerges as the a training ground for
decision making progress your AI learns
through trial and error navigating
decision processes and rewards it's a
again to teaching your AI to play a
strategic game where the choices made
result in either positive or negative
consequences framework like open AI gym
and tensor flow agents become the arenas
for your AI to practice and refine its
decision- making skills reinforcement
learning trans transforms your AI into a
strategic thinker capable of making
optimal choices in Dynamic and uncertain
environments the journey wouldn't be
complete without the touch of cloud
computing offering a playground for your
AI to frolic and scale distributed
computing becomes the team sport of the
AI World enabling your digital companion
to handle massive computations
efficiently imagine your AI
collaborating with other digital
entities each contributing its
computational power to tackle complex
tasks git the AI memory becomes the
historian tracking changes and fostering
collaboration among developers git is
not just a Version Control tool it's the
time machine that allows you to revisit
and understand the evolution of your AI
projects model serving Frameworks such
as tensor flow ser serving or flask
become the waiters in the AI restaurant
presenting your models on a silver
platter these Frameworks ensure that
your AI models are served in production
ready to make an impact model serving is
the grand finale of your AI Journey
where the fruits of your labor are
presented to the world making a tangible
difference in real world
scenarios in this collaborative Symphony
of skills each note played by
programming languages mathematical
foundations and specialized AI tools
contributes to the crescendo of
mastering artificial intelligence the
journey is not just a technical Endeavor
it's a creative exploration where your
AI becomes an artist a mathematician and
a problem solver all in one dive in
experiment and relish the creative
journey of mastering AI where the
horizons are boundless and the
possibilities are as vast as the digital
sees themselves staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security and AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here